can we pull back
historically speaking and in terms of
the big picture of cryptocurrency real
quick
and ask the question what is cardano we
started talking about already the
consensus algorithm of cardano
takes but maybe when you look at the
history books you know sort of uh
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy and
cardona will have one sentence
uh what's that one sentence going to be
and in general what's like division
in the context of the history of
cryptocurrency you have like this
whiteboard overview video they
you uh talk about the three generations
of cryptocurrency where cardano's the
third
so that's a like five different
questions way of asking the exact same
thing you can answer however the how you
want
you know car i always term cardano as
like a foss a financial operating system
and nobody likes it and
everybody picks on me for using that
term but basically the idea is that you
know the world runs on systems
especially the financial world you have
you know the bis and
swift and all this other stuff and
these protocols allow you to move value
around and represent things like
identity
and uh and allow you to express yourself
in some way
and those protocols for the most part
work well for
people in rich countries and they don't
work so well for people who aren't in
rich countries
and so the point of what we do or at
least what i do
and what my company does is we think a
lot about how do we build a universal
protocol that
does all the stuff the legacy system has
but just does it better faster and
cheaper for all
everybody in the world and everybody has
equal access to it you know so it's the
people's protocol you know you have a
situation where the guy in senegal
has the same access that i do or bill
gates does or someone else who's
kind of higher on the spectrum of wealth
and power
and so uh that is what we seek to
achieve
but then the question is well is cardano
the solution you know is it that is that
that
thing and the answer is no because you
need
a lot more evolution you need decades of
evolution to kind of work your way there
and in many ways the work is never quite
done but it's
better than what came before why because
you you have a realization that first
the control of the system needs to be
more balanced and nuanced
and it needs to be more democratic so
there's this
sustainability component of who's in
charge and how do you pay for things
well the system can print its own money
so it always has the ability to have a
budget okay so there's a treasury idea
and then there's a voting thing well the
same things that allow you to move money
around
allow you to represent votes so you can
do e-voting with the type of system okay
and you know if you played nomic in the
1980s or peter superfan or any of these
things you can build a self-evolving
system
you can actually create a game where the
rules can be voted on and change
in the game itself great okay so that
exists there
and then you say okay well but this
thing still has to touch the legacy
world there has to be cash in and cash
out and these types of things
so this is this interoperability thing
you need a wi-fi or a bluetooth moment
for the industry because nothing
understands each other right now they're
all these chains are
blind deaf and dumb to each other and
then there's this thing that has to work
at a huge scale
like billions of people and we've done
that but we've done that with large
multinational trillion dollar companies
with centralized infrastructure we've
never really done that with
one master protocol that somehow does it
for everyone the closest approximation
is probably bittorrent
and there is you know there was it's a
cool protocol but it doesn't have
all the um necessary to necessary to do
something like this
so cardano is just our first
approximation and like any good system
it's we wanted it to be self-evolving so
once you get the philosophy out of
where's the target
of what you want to do then you build a
community now it's over a million people
strong
and that community keeps growing and
they keep pushing the system in that
particular direction
and what's nice about is if you build
the right philosophy within the system
it doesn't need founders this is the
great election of satoshi it doesn't
need founders to be able to get there
so uh you know if you look at the
academic side that's very decentralized
we have more than 30 different
contributors for 105 papers
and that set keeps growing within the
next five years it'll probably be two
three four hundred different scientists
from all across the world some from
russia and some from india some from
china
and some from japan and america and
africa and south america
and the faces change the language has
changed the cultures change
but the process stays the same and that
is a permanent organ
within what we have constructed as a
system it's the same situation entering
marketplaces like we entered ethiopia
what are we doing there we have five
million people in ethiopia we're getting
them
digital identity and we're dragging that
digital identity into the system because
that's the most fundamental thing of a
financial operating system
you need to know who people are in order
to be able to do business with them give
them
credit be able to give them economic
agency and sort of thing
but once they're there they're going to
grow up with that system
they're going to deploy applications on
that system they're going to build on
that system or use it every day
for getting a loan or payments and so
forth and if they have pain points what
they're going to do is
evolve that system to be able to
mitigate manage
those particular pain points to a point
where the system is competitive
for it so my job is to be
we have this tagline in our company
cascading disruption our my job is to be
the first domino
just kind of knock it over and watch the
cascade and it kind of blows and blows
and blows up until eventually
you know it gets to where we need to go
and what i was trying to think about
with cardano was
how do you build the minimum viable set
of
tools and social processes that once we
push the domino the system will just
evolve to a point where eventually it
can grow to fill that need
not out of charity but out of
self-interest
people want things better faster cheaper
you know people
want to have economic agency especially
when they lack it
nobody wants to grow up in a world where
they're unbanked and they have no access
to marketplaces they're going to seek it
look at mpesa it's a great example of
that like cell phone minutes
they're using as a currency so that's
where we're at and i say a few more
years i think we'll have
that right minimum viable set of
dynamics inside the system
and then it's inevitable in my view that
it'll kind of grow and consume and
become this concept and what's really
cool is there's competition in the
systems and concepts so china is trying
to do the same thing
they're saying how do we de-dollarize
the world and create a digital yuan
so they have a very top-down notion of
how to apply this technology and bring
it in and they even have an identity
system they're building in parallel
called social credit
we have an identity system a tolerance
that we're putting in ours is bottom up
and you own your own identity social
credit you have no idea you just have a
number and some computer's given it to
you but they're both trying to do the
exact same thing
and it's going to be this clash of
cultures at some point between
the open fosters and the top-down
authoritarian fossils and
probably some hegelian dialectic action
will happen and we'll create
you know some sort of somewhat close
somewhat authoritarian libertarian
utopia yeah most likely would be
ai's battling in the space of fossils so
i really like this idea financial
operating system but
what this the letter f so financial
is this just um a basic
mechanism with which you can have social
interaction therefore therefore or all
kinds of interactions therefore have an
identity
like is f essential to this yeah because
that's how people care you need
resources to survive
and you know finances is kind of like
this field of of
managing your resources in an
intelligent way and you could call it
sofi too social finance you know the the
the nomenclature hasn't exactly been
settled for our industry and that's fun
but basically the concept is that you
you you have something
and you want to be able to store it
transform it trade it and use it to
survive
and the question is what rails do you do
that on do you do those on centralized
controlled rails where there are these
third parties that are you know
basically able to to live off those
things come very fat and epotistic or do
you want to do it on rails where there's
no middleman
you have a direct relationship with
whoever you're doing business and if you
invite more people to the transaction
they're middlemen of value
not necessity and that's really the the
i would like to say the resident detroit
of our space the reason we exist is to
try to figure out a way to kill the
middleman
and try to figure out a way that we can
better quantify
value and transform it move it
manipulate it and in many ways we've
actually discovered some amazing things
in the last 10 years as an industry like
we've kind of created the financial stem
cell
this idea of a token can now is just as
well be a national currency as a cbdc
as it can represent a crypto kitty you
know the same
architecture can do stuff at the nation
scale can do stuff for a 12 year old kid
in texas
it's pretty amazing to see that
you